we're getting acupuncture acupuncture
acupuncture is based on energy and it's
based on harmonizing the energy of the
body i will be putting acupuncture
needles and acupuncture points to help
harmonize the body and bring balance to
the system i'm very nervous when it
comes to needles so
this would be a good day to conquer my
fear but he's not nervous when it comes
to being shirtless
it's not gonna like make me react weird
or anything of it i'm not gonna
what do you think's gonna happen
fart or something
so i'm gonna fill your pulse now
and that's one of the diagnostic tools
is feeling the pulse and looking at the
tongue what does looking at the tongue
tell you the tongue is one of the only
muscles that you can see outside the
body so when you look at the tongue it
can tell you what's happening inside
first needle's going to go in
okay oh do you stick them in my head
oh my god
is there one in right now
ryan what does it look like
you have an antenna on your head
it's weird like you feel a little
something but it definitely doesn't hurt
cut that a little bit
oh my god you're gonna stick one there
[ __ ] me
and how many needles will you use on me
usually i don't put in more than
20 to 30.
yeah quite good
very relaxed
i feel really relaxed i don't know if
it's just the placebo effect but i feel
very
in my body i feel very like chill i
don't think i'm like on the cloud nine
that he is i feel pretty sleepy okay get
in a good way not like a tired one i
could see myself going and doing it
again depending on the benefits that i
feel
let's see how i sleep tonight i'll let
you know
i think ryan's just sad that he had to
do this post interview with a shirt on
like i think that's the only like
that train is never late always on time
you